-Cute dog.
-You have a nice dog as well.
Angie, down.
Bruno, down.
Down. All the way down. Bruno, down.
Have a nice day, sir.
[man] Charlie!
Stop with the Charlie [bleep].
His name's Bruno.
He even looks like a Charlie. I love him.
-It's Bruno.
-Charlie.
Hey, hey, don't touch my...
♪ La, la, la, la♪
-...dog.
-Sorry, I didn't mean to.
-He's just so cute.
-Bruno. Roll over.
You should take my number.
What is your daily routine with Bruno?
[Malcolm] I brush his teeth, I make sure
his pearly whites are shiny,
make sure his breath is nice and fresh.
I would love to be a part of that routine.
[Lulu moans] Malcolm.
Whoa! You almost hit Bruno
with that thing!
Well, maybe Bruno shouldn't take up
so much space on the sidewalk!
You know the rules. No dogs allowed.
Hello. Hi, sweetheart.
Hey, don't touch my dog.
[Maureen] I ain't never seen
nobody so rude!
Hey, man, that's not a dog!
He sounds no good.
A real piece of sh--.
Hey!
There's some worse things on the street
than some dog caca.
["Il Barbiere Di Siviglia:
Una Voce Poco Fa" plays]
[screaming]
I can't talk to you
with that dog humping your leg.
I don't want to anger it.